longest running show on the strip
legends in concert is back
earlier today i spoke with mc frank
mourinho about the return to the
tropicana
frank marino welcome back how you
feeling buddy
i'm feeling really great i am so ready
to get back to work
so when does the show start what's the
actual return date for legends in
concert
legends and concert starts on the 27th
of may it'll be
uh three nights a week to start it'll be
thursday friday saturdays at 7
30 and then of course then as the crowds
come back to vegas when things open up
they're going to add on another day and
another day until it's the
normal full week so have you been
exercising or driving special to stay in
uh performance
shape when i tell you i've been
exercising like crazy i've been uh
practicing in the high heel shoes i have
i've been doing writing new jokes i want
to make sure they're really cool you
know not
intensive jokes would you know how it is
these days but i wanted to talk about i
knew it was a really strong disease when
kovit was able to keep men out of the
bars and get them home to their women by
10 o'clock every night
so you know stuff like that and your
your official role is you're you're
emceeing everything
um so are you are you are you done up as
john rivers you come out as yourself
what's your actual role in the show
yeah so i'll be doing drone rivers we're
also going to have elvis presley rod
stewart and of course miss tina turner
and i'll be like the silver thread that
ties it all together in between our
reacts
and you know where all the beautiful bob
mackie gowns and stuff that we do all
the time
yeah i think it's very special that you
guys are coming back here at the end of
the may at in the
end of may because legends in concert
the first very show
was may 5th 1983. what's it like to be
part of the longest running show on the
strip
well can i tell you from day one i used
to uh go see that show
as a fan i was on the john river show
one day and she said what would you do
if i passed away i said i'd have to join
legends of concert
but yes one of my favorite shows that
i've ever seen
and also i'm the longest writing
headliner on this trip i came the
following year
in 1984 so there's a really good
marriage there
so two icons uh the longest running show
and the longest running performer in las
vegas
you look like you did back in 1984
you're ageless frank barino
well that's why i keep coming on your
show because i enjoyed those compliments
he looks amazing he's such an amazing
guy and so
extremely talented and hilarious so
excited to see vegas opening up again
for sure may 27th legends and concert is
back